who among the cast is the most excited
to be at the con like who wants to be on
the floor oh we all are oh my gosh we
are just so ecstatic to be here in san
diego 2022 like comic-con it was a
matter of time for it to finally come
out of the woodwork storing this
pandemic and now the outpour fans and
just the frequency and energy is just
really really next level it's so amazing
and to feel the proud family love all
around us has been incredible
the panel was so fun so you must have
people that are like they grew up with
the show and now they've got families of
their own what kind of stories are you
getting from these people about how the
show has been a part of their lives
well i mean for me playing los angeles
and being of mixed descent and you know
having a really strong leading female
character for the latinx community i
mean la sienna had her coming of age
quinceanera episode this past season i
think now we're talking about topics
that have always been there but people
are just awoke so you know kind of
magnifying in on activism and lgbtq
community and cultural different topics
i mean for me i think having the
previous fans and now the new ones which
sometimes are the parents and now the
kids right um getting a chance to just
maybe learn something new or just kind
of uh
elevate a little bit the topic of
conversation within the family dynamic
when you're watching our show just put
the phones away and
have a good time yeah people connect
with this show so much and it's so
beautiful to hear their stories
and to to hear them
speak about how important it's been to
feel heard and that this show really has
always stuck with them
and being heard and i love that because
i know it applies so much in my own life
with my kids
and this this desire to really
communicate with each other and
i think this is so special because it's
so much more than a show for us it
really
is uh
is something so pure of heart and
there's so much love and there's always
been so much love and it really is an
extended family
having been with these characters for
such a long time is there anything that
still surprises you about them
yes we just keep peeling back the onion
layer after layer after a layer i'm like
this is so awesome like zoe's like on
this constant
road of self-discovery which i feel like
i'm always on this constant road of
self-discovery and so i feel like we're
in our expansion together and i get so
excited by that and i i love the way the
friends and the family
interact the dynamics it's so inspiring
i mean i feel like glossier she's still
her sassy spunky self but now she's
definitely learning how to have her
voice be
you know
you know it's shining but she's learning
how to kind of just maneuver a little
bit and then she's learning her lessons
maybe a little faster we're learning
those morals and principles and doing a
full circle moment which listen you know
la cienega is going to be you know
penny's mirror that's what i like to say
penny proud's mirror i'm a reflection of
you and so forth but at the end of the
day our dynamic dj zoe and penny and
lasianica it's never going to go
anywhere and that's what's beautiful is
we've been friends some from day one and
to show families yeah friendship is is
love love is where it's at yeah
there are a lot of amazing guest stars
that are going to be appearing in season
two who are you excited for fans to hear
uh as guest characters in the show
well should we uh ceelo is amazing
ceelo i'm obsessed with when he played
the panda like that track i'm gonna
listen to it over and over again this
cast is so incredible and the amazing
guest stars that we've had i mean
literally i would read the scripts and
be like wait like the real lizzo is
doing it like
like lizzo lizzo or is there like a
pretend lizzo i like nasdaq's wait like
is this a real nausea you know like you
just it's so incredible and i think
that's been such a beautiful part of the
proud family always and like people just
connect to it and you you feel so proud
to be a part of
this show that people really connect
with because we also have artists and
other actors and you know they're the
ones coming to our show wanting to be a
part of it which is really really
humbling and deep gratitude for that and
and the diversity aspect of it too to me
is what makes the show unique because
there's really nothing like it on tv you
know growing up as a little girl in new
york city and sitting in the middle of
my living room trying to identify with
someone and resonate with that person
it was you know a dime a dozen so now
now that i'm a new mom of an 11 month
old you know she'll get a chance to
watch our show hopefully as she gets
older and you know can relate to it
it's amazing full circle moments all
around thank you so much for your time
you're so sweet congratulations you